así que aquí nos quedamos estábamos
viendo esta función paramétrica de una
curva cuya gráfica era esta de aquí era
una hélice en tres dimensiones y
estábamos intentando averiguar su
curvatura y bueno la forma en la que lo
estábamos pensando es que tenemos un
círculo podemos fijarnos en el círculo
que abraza más cercanamente a la hélice
o bueno otra forma de pensarlo como
había dicho era imaginar que estamos
volando una nave y que toda la
maquinaria se atasca y lo que queremos
es saber qué círculo en el espacio
estamos trazando y bueno también
habíamos dicho en el vídeo pasado que la
curvatura era 1 / r o bien si nos
regresamos a mi dibujo de preescolar es
porque en definitiva no tengo grandes
cualidades en el dibujo pero bueno aquí
teníamos esta hélice y con lo que vamos
a trabajar es con esta función del
vector unitario es decir para cualquier
valor dado de ese de cualquier punto en
esta curva esta función
nos va a dar 1
unitario y tangente a la curva y bueno
para obtener la curvatura que es un
objetivo necesitamos encontrar a camps
que habíamos dicho que es igual a la
longitud oa la normal de la derivada de
este vector unitario tangente con
respecto a la curva es decir queremos la
magnitud de esta derivada y como ya
hemos visto en algunos vídeos de esta
misma fórmula esto es lo mismo que la
longitud de la derivada de t con
respecto al parámetro con respecto a
términos coulant y bueno aquí todavía no
tenemos la longitud unitaria tenemos
solamente un pequeño cambio en tema y
bueno si queremos corregirlo a esto hay
que dividirlo entre la magnitud o la
normal de la derivada de s con respecto
de nuevo el parámetro que en realidad se
observa todo esto es la longitud del
arco de la curva entre la magnitud de la
derivada con respecto a t y bueno
observa que tenemos mucho trabajo
todavía por delante entonces vamos a
hacerlo lo primero que voy a hacer
debido a que tenemos todas estas
fracciones es
este mismo vector pero de una manera más
simple voy a escribir a este efector
unitario tema cómo y qué te parece si
dividimos todo entre la raíz de 26 sobre
5 y esto me va a quedar como menos cinco
veces el seno de t entre la raíz de 26
solamente subimos el 5 al numerador y
hacemos lo mismo para el cocedero aquí
me quedaría 5 veces el coste no de t
entre la raíz de 26 y bueno por último
tengo un quinto entre la raíz de 26
sobre 5 eso es fácil eso es simplemente
1 sobre la raíz de 26 de lujo así que
ahora vamos a derivar lo porque la
fórmula nos pide que derivamos que
encontremos la derivada de la función
vectorial tangente entonces esto me va a
quedar como la derivada de t con
respecto al parámetro con respecto a t
minúscula y va a ser igual
bueno tomemos la derivada de cada una de
las componentes menos 50 dtm esto al
derivar lo me va a dar menos 5 coseno de
t entre la raíz de 26
por la constante no lo olvides de manera
muy similar pasa en la segunda
componente la derivada de cinco veces
consta en 9 t
es menos cinco veces el seno de tema
entre la raíz de 26 y por último la
derivada de una constante con respecto a
t es cero nos queda nada y bueno ya que
tenemos ahora este vector el siguiente
paso es tomarnos la magnitud de este
mismo vector por lo tanto la magnitud de
la derivada de la función tangente con
respecto al parámetro va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de la suma de los
cuadrados de cada componente es decir a
la raíz cuadrada de y bueno el cuadrado
de la primera componente es 25 por el
coseno cuadrado de t y esto dividido
entre 26 porque recuerda la raíz
cuadrada de 26 elevada al cuadrado es 26
ya esto le vamos a sumar pues me va a
quedar algo similar acá abajo me quedan
25 veces
el seno cuadrado de t entre también 26 y
bueno de aquí observa podemos factorizar
bueno podemos sacar como factor común a
25 sobre 26 entonces me quedaría la raíz
cuadrada todo esto va a ser igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 25 sobre 26 que
multiplica quien bueno multiplica al
coseno cuadrado más el seno cuadrado y
eso está bastante bien porque el coseno
cuadrado más el seno cuadrado es la
identidad que siempre nos encontramos en
los círculos sabemos que esto es igual a
1 y simplemente nos quedamos con la raíz
cuadrada de 25 sobre 26 y esto es
bastante bonito no crees así que bueno
vamos a introducirlos aquí en nuestra
fórmula ya tenemos el numerador el
numerador es la raíz cuadrada de 25
sobre 26 y bueno también en el vídeo
pasado ya habíamos encontrado la
magnitud de la derivada en sí misma
recuerdan que fue una de las cosas que
hicimos para encontrar el vector tánger
y es justo de dónde proviene esta raíz
de 26 entre 5 lo borré en el vídeo
pasado para hacer un poco de espacio
menem pero si observas ese vídeo estoy
seguro que vas a saber de dónde sale
esta raíz de 26 sobre 5 y de hecho lo
voy a escribir pero lo voy a escribir de
esta manera lo voy a escribir como la
raíz de 26 sobre 25 es lo mismo estás
acuerdo solo estoy metiendo este 5
dentro del radical y bueno si lo ves de
rápido tal vez estés tentado a cancelar
estos dos y decir que el resultado es 1
pero ojo de hecho son inversos
multiplicativos 1 es 26 sobre 25 y el
otro es 25 sobre 26 entonces si ponemos
todo esto dentro de la raíz cuadrada voy
a obtener lo siguiente voy a obtener la
raíz cuadrada observa de 25 sobre 26
este es mi numerador ya todo esto lo voy
a dividir entre mi denominador que es 26
sobre 25 y haciendo esta división entre
fracciones me va a quedar
es muy fácil me va a quedar la raíz
cuadrada de 25 esto elevado al cuadrado
entre 26 elevado al cuadrado y es muy
padre porque pues los cuadrados se
cancelan y simplemente me quedan 25
sobre 26 y esa es justo nuestra
curvatura justo aquí tenemos la
respuesta acá es un poquito menor que 1
lo que significa que estamos copiando un
poco menos de lo que curva una
circunferencia con radio de 1 lo cual
tiene sentido ya que si regresamos a la
imagen y observan esta hélice
está completamente aplanada si
imaginamos que toda la apretamos en el
plano x ya sólo tendríamos un círculo de
radio 1 pero ojo al estirarla de regreso
tenemos la componente zeta
que la hace un poco más recta y es por
ello que la curvatura baja un poco
porque la hélice es un poco más recta
bien así que aquí tenemos la curvatura
de la hélice y bueno este fue un ejemplo
muy bonito de cómo puedes encontrar la
curvatura caminando directamente del eid
de encontrar la derivada de t con
respecto a s ya sabes obteniendo este
vector unitario tangente y obteniendo
también la longitud de este arco
unitario y en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
trabajar otro ejemplo donde solo usemos
esta fórmula algo tal vez un poco más
complicado pero que podamos resolver con
esta misma fórmula y utilizando lo que
sabemos así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo